et
il
je
le puritanisme américain avait longtemps
tenu sous le boisseau les tendances
homosexuelles la révolution des femmes
la libération explosive des moeurs a
conduit les homosexuels à sortir de
l'ombre et à revendiquer le droit
d'exister au grand jour sans brimades
sociale ou légal
je m'appelle bruce valeurs reçues le
directeur du mouvement homosexuel
nationale à new york
notre organisation représente les
homosexuels dans tout le pays
une partie de nos activités est relié au
mouvement féministe
l'autre concerne spécifiquement le
mouvement homosexuel
j'aimerais vous présenter d'abord
l'homme avec lequel je partage ma vie
bill blanc tu sais mon époux je ne sais
pas si vous avez un mot en français pour
désigner cela ici on ne manque pas
beaucoup les mots de marie ou de femme
tu ne correspondent à rien je vous
présente aussi de nos amies lesbiennes
marguerite et caroline il faut ajouter
encore que si vous regardez bien mes
amis ils ne correspondent absolument pas
l'image stéréotypée qu'on se fait d'un
homosexuel
la plupart d'entre nous sont dans ce cas
en fait un bon nombre de gens qui sont
vos amis vos proches vos voisins de
palier état d'hommes et de femmes que
vous croisez dans la vie vous ne savez
pas qu'ils sont homosexuels
et pourtant ils le sont je crois que
c'était important de lire sexuelle je me
savais simplement à cause du rapport
kinsey mais ça ne soyez pas du tout en
tant que lesbienne je vois deux
directions d'actions possibles
d'abord la lutte très âpre pour nos
droits dans laquelle nous sommes engagés
à new york
nous essayons d'obtenir d'habiter ou
nous voulons le droit de garder notre
emploi le droit à toutes les
infrastructures publiques tout en étant
ouvertement homosexuel
pour ce qui concerne le mouvement des
lesbiennes nous essayons nous définir
nous mêmes
jusqu'à maintenant ce qui se passait
c'est que les autres le définissait time
magazine et d'autres journaux ne les
acquis nous étions or ce qui nous
intéresse c'est que des lesbiennes parle
d'elle-même et disent qu'ils sont
vraiment encore dans ce pays des lois
très répressives au terme desquelles il
est interdit d'avoir des rapports
homosexuels même entre adultes depuis
longtemps la plupart des pays européens
ont aboli ces lois vous en campagne pour
qu'on les abolisse ici nous avons déjà
réussi d'entrée et a aujourd'hui
certains tentent même d'élever le
problème homosexuel ou plan politique et
électoral comme le fait avait mellick
le mouvement homosexuel c'est un peu
comme le mouvement des femmes et il ya
quelques années ont commencé à en parler
mais les gens ne connaissaient pas grand
chose dans certaines villes comme san
francisco on connaît le mouvement mais
ailleurs presque pas et si je suis élu
adjoint au maire ce sera à la une de
tous les journaux
mais déjà la prise de conscience
commence
et puis si vous êtes élu vous aurez le
pouvoir de changer la condition des
homosexuels
non je ne nommerai pas le pouvoir mais
ma position me donnera une tribune et
cela peut aider à changer les choses